امين ما اهميه ان تثبت روسيا موضوع رد
الفعل لاستهداف
اراضيها في بريانس قبل ايام من خلال توسيع
الهجمات في انحاء كبيره في اوكرانيا
[تصفيق]
نعم سلمى هذا
وصفه شاهدناه مرات عديده خلال هذه الحرب
ليست هذه هي المره الاولى التي تستهدف
فيها روسيا بشكل واسع عبر ضربات صاروخيه
مواقع اوكرانيه شاهدنا ذلك عندما كانت
موسكو قد اتهمت الجانب الاوكراني بتفجير
جسر القرن وايضا بهجمات اخرى سابقه تعرضت
على سبيل المثال فيها روسيا
لهجمات اتهمت في الجانب الاوكراني حتى
داخل العمق الروسي هذا التوقيت طبعا هذا
الهجوم جاء بعد اسبوع بالتمام والكمال بعد
ما سمته روسيا بالهجمات الارهابيه في
مقاطعه التي تتهم في الجانب الاوكراني
بشكل مباشر وهناك ايضا اختلاف او تغيير
لنقل في نوعيه وفي حجم الصواريخ التي
استخد حتى في هذه الضربه روسيا استخدمت
اليوم صواريخ كينجال لاول مره وزاره
الدفاع تؤكد استخدام هذا الصاروخ الذي
تبلغ او يبلغ مداه الف كيلومتر
ويعني سرعته تفوق سرعه الصوت بعشر مرات
لكن وزير الدفاع الروسي ايضا كان في شهر
اغسطس من العام الماضي قد قال بان روسيا
استخدمت هذه الصواريخ لكن لم يشير في اي
ضربات بالتحديد على كل حال هذه الضربه
كانت كبيره الوزاره وزاره الدفاع اليوم في
بيانها قالت بانها رد مباشر على هجوم
بريانسكو وبانها حققت الاهداف المرجوه
منها بتدمير منشات للطاقه لها ارتباط
مباشر بالتصنيع العسكري ايضا منشات عسكريه
وخطه للسكك الحديديه لنقل القوات وايضا
اسلحه غربيه الصنع كما قالت
طبعا في خضن هذا الحديث وهذه النتائج التي
كشفت عنها وزاره الدفاع اليوم
السلطات المواليه لروسيا ايضا كانت صباح
اليوم قد اكدت انقطاع التيار الكهربائي عن
محطه لطاقه النوويه لكنها في المقابل قللت
من
مدى تاثير هذه الخطوه باعتبار ان المولد
او المفاعل الوحيد داخل محطه لا يعمل منذ
سبتمبر الماضي وانقطاع الكهرباء كان اليوم
قد اثر فقط على
التدفئه او تبريد بعض المفاعلات التي هي
في الحقيقه غير نشطه ولا تنتج التيار
الكهربائي بحسب مسؤول روسي هناك الوزاره
كما سبق وذكرت تحدثت بالتفصيل عن الهجمات
الصاروخيه التي شنتها روسيا اليوم على
مناطق متفرقه من اوكرانيا فلنستمع الى ما
قاله المتحدث باسم الوزاره ايغور كان
شيكوف بهذا الشان
ردا على الاعمال الارهابيه التي نظمها
نظام كييف في الثاني من مارس من هذا العام
لمقاطعه بريانسك شنت القوات الروسيه ضربه
انتقاميه واسعه النطاق وتم تدمير المرافق
الرئيسيه للبنيه التحتيه العسكريه
الاوكرانيه ومؤسسات المجمع الصناعي
العسكري ومرافق الطاقه باستخدام اسلحه
جويه وبحريه وبريه بعيده المدى عاليه
الدقه بما في ذلك نظام صواريخ كنجال تم
تحقيق هدف العمليه بضرب جميع المرافق
المستهدفه
من موسكو امين درغامي ومانيكييف حسن
الشوبكي شكرا لكما